hey youtubers is Charlie so sophie
Turner and the producers of Game of
Thrones Season 5 have been talking about
some crazy things happening with the
Sansa character so I wanted to talk
about her progression and what I think
you know some of the changes they made
to the books mean for where they're
taking her in season five even though
the TV show is changing a lot of things
about the books I think that Dan and
Dave are taking Sansa in the same
direction that they think they George
are Martin is taking her but for those
that are wondering
Sansa's character caught up to her book
story in season four so whatever happens
to her in season five it's beyond the
books real quick reminder new round of
the weekly giveaway I'm giving away a
copy of the season 4 blu-ray all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I do
have some other cool stuff to mention
that I'm gonna fit at the end of the
video like this badass poster they
released and the HBO streaming service
so all that stuff after we get through
some dark Sansa just careful for
spoilers for everything through season 4
on the show and all the book stuff that
they've covered on the show so far so
let's start with the idea of dark Sansa
what do I mean when I say dark Sansa but
mostly I'm talking about the direction
that our character is headed both sophie
Turner and the producers have talked in
very general terms that Sansa is going
to have some traumatic i opening
experiences in season 5 up to this point
you know you still kind of consider her
sweet Sansa sweet summer child Sansa
she's like one of those characters that
totally bought into the idea of chivalry
and the fantasy of real society and then
over the last four seasons and the first
three books that fantasy slowly gets
burned down in front of her she gets
betrothed to the future king who winds
up being a total monster gets brutalized
by Knights like sir Meryn Trant here and
then proceeds to get rescued by people
that she thinks are terrible slowly
along the way her idea of reality just
gets chipped away where does that leave
her in season 5 so if you remember at
the end of season 4 Littlefinger
convinced Sansa to deceive Lord Royce
and the other Nobles of the Vale after
he sent Lysa through the moon door
they always hated Littlefinger he's an
impostor in their eyes so Sansa could
have totally told the truth and hung him
out to dry
I don't know if you could call it
telling a bold-faced lie courageous but
this is one of the first time Sansa
acted in her own interest even if it
meant doing something bad doing bad
things for the right reasons or doing
bad things in your own self-interest
that is what playing the game of Thrones
is all about whenever she was back in
King's Landing I think she mostly
applied avoidance tactics like where she
just tried to blend
with the furniture hoping that Joffrey
would see something shiny and distract
him then you get to the end of season
four and she's learning to manipulate
people with with little fingers help one
of my favorite clever Sansa moments from
from when this starts to happen is when
Littlefinger visits her after that
meeting with Lord Royce and she tells
him I know what you want it's like her
saying I get it now I understand what
you're after and then the next time we
see her she's dyed her hair black and
she's wearing this awesome looking black
dress so when you look at her in these
shots from the season 5 trailer you can
see she's starting to look more and more
like her mother Catelyn so what it seems
like the producers are doing is giving
her some of the more violent aspects of
the post red wedding Catelyn Stark I
think in one of my earlier videos I said
the name Sansa Stoneheart and I think
there might be a little confusing for
some people I wasn't saying that I think
she's literally going to go through the
Lady Stoneheart storyline I think it
just means that she's going to start
murdering people in the name of
vengeance with a lot of help from
Littlefinger think about it this way on
the list of traumatic things that can
happen two characters going from sweet
summer child to cold-blooded killer is
pretty high in the list and the trailer
even teases this a little Littlefinger
tells Sansa there's no justice in this
world
not unless we make it and then later he
says avenge them as we see you know
Sansa crying her eyes out it seems like
little fingers trying to sell Sansa on a
complex revenge plot that involves
murdering lots of phrase lots of
Bolton's
lhasa Lannisters the only potential
issues with this are that Santa's TV
show story has already caught up with
her book story for those that haven't
read the books
Sansa's story in the books ends at the
end of book 4 whenever they had this
meeting with Lords of the Vale this is
like the last scene that we get with her
there was a chapter that george RR
martin wrote for winds of winter for her
character but because both of those
books because books four and five occur
in the same timeframe I think that it
was probably just this last scene that
we got with her with Littlefinger in
season 4 she's supposed to be a POV
character in winds of winter but we have
no idea where her story is going so I'm
just choosing to assume that Dan and
Dave are taking Sansa in the direction
that they logically think George R
Martin is taking her but you can never
predict what George R Martin was gonna
do next another really cool thing to
think about is that the false name that
Sansa uses whenever they go to the Vale
to hide out is stone so Sansa stone
dark Sansa I just I think it all fits
together there are a lot of you that
have asked me about Michele Fairley's
name appearing on the IMDB page for the
season 5 finale for season 5 episode 10
just because anybody with a keyboard
it's a lot to edit IMDB I wouldn't take
that as being fact officially Michele
Fairley's people have said that she has
nothing to do with Game of Thrones I
mean you can hold out hope for her
making a guest appearance but I don't
think it's gonna happen
more cool Sansa stuff though so sophie
turner just cast is jean grey in the new
x-men franchise so she is in line to
become the next Dark Phoenix sophie
turner said that it was her recent work
on Game of Thrones that got the x-men
producers interested in her Jean Grey
very caring sensitive person that winds
up becoming the crazy cosmic spirit of
vengeance so I'm kind of wondering if
Bryan Singer and the x-men people saw
footage of her in season 5 and thought
she'd do a really good job of pulling
off a character to go from timid to
really evil badass I mean I don't know
if they did or not but so if he turned
ridore he filmed most of season 5
whenever she auditioned for x-men so
here's my big question for you guys do
you want to see a stabby er version of
Santa in season 5 or if you don't want
to see her go in that direction what do
you want the producers to do with the
character I'm not expecting Sansa to die
in season 5 but I guess it's still a
possibility it just seems like the
producers are setting her on the path to
becoming more of a badass in her own way
you know just like Aria and Braavos
speaking which this poster they just
released it I mean it looks awesome but
it makes it look like Tyrion is going to
encounter drogon while he's sailing to
Pentos they might tease that but I think
this is just like the season 4 trailer
whenever we saw drogon shadow of her
King's Landing it's not something that
ended up happening on the show it was
just like a WTF hype moment to get
everyone crazy excited about dragons but
I do think that we're gonna see drill
GaN strafing the coast for food just
explain the giveaway for new people so
I'm doing a weekly Game of Thrones
giveaway whenever we get to episode 1
I'm giving away signed copies of feast
for crows and dance with dragons signed
by George R Martin that is in their
heart bags which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Sarah Weller you and a copy of
the season 4 blu-ray so just be sure to
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info I'm also
probably going to give away some
subscriptions to the HBO streaming
service they haven't announced an
official start date yet but they're
probably going to open it up for
subscriptions at the beginning of April
the season 5 premiere is a
twelve so what they'll probably do is
they'll open it up for subscriptions
within about two weeks of that they
haven't said how much it's gonna cost
but most of the best estimates that I've
seen so far are fifteen US dollars and
they haven't announced whether or not
it's going to be available in
international countries but worst case
scenario you access it just like you
access HBO GO
with a proxy service so even if you're
outside of the US you should still be
able to pay money in legit watch Game of
Thrones like you won't have to pirate it
I'm totally down with whatever ways you
guys use to watch the show but I do ask
that you guys not paste pirate streaming
links in the comments right now we're
within the six week window of season
five starting so I hope you're all
getting crazy excited please leave me
all your requests for bonus videos
there's still plenty of time to do all
kinds of fun stuff between now and then
I think my next video is probably gonna
be a Daenerys video so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll post that
next week while you guys wait for that
to drop you can click here for my Jon
Snow video and you can click here for my
list of unexpected deaths that I think
might be happening thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight
you